here we are on overtime well you're an
ESPN now yeah what are your thoughts on
deflategate they want to know really
they want to know that yeah ooh I think
everyone does it's the big story I think
you got to call it like you see it and
Tom Brady cheated and he lied about
cheating yeah that's who it is and um it
says I like the guy yeah want to like
the guy he seems like I have friends who
played with him said he's a great human
being but you don't have to connect the
dots if you squint the dots start to
blur together he he knew what was
happening what you wouldn't penalty
should again yeah good question that is
a good question what do you think that
he can go to the Indianapolis Colts
locker room and write a hundred times I
will not use deflated footballs ever
again and that's it
I think you should you know a couple of
games at the beginning yeah a couple of
games seems about right
touch those balls several times a game
they never they never knew they were but
you know give you a few more ever notice
any more games than you get for hitting
somebody right right what what what
bothers me about this story it's the
same thing that bothers me about so many
stories which is that nobody in this
country anymore seems to be able to just
go oh yet two things are true he's great
and he cheated right you know why can't
we do that why can't we say gray's
anymore I mean it's either black or it's
white and I know that's not a good day
the vast vast majority of Muslims are
not terrorists but there is a special
problem with the Islamic culture right
now what can't we agree on those two
things they're both obvious and true how
about this ever I mean everything is
like that those are both obviously true
can it can it also be obviously true
that Tom Brady is a good guy and he
cheated you know in some sports baseball
if you doctor the ball if you cheat it's
kind of like a he's one of the good old
boys trying hard if you move your ball
in golf
nobody wants to do business with you
right that means what Golf is the most
morally upstanding I don't know what
there is to play I don't know I think
they're not saying just saying didn't
Bill Clinton have a bad reputation for
doing that if you kick your ball on the
golf course you are looked at as an
untrustworthy I will stay away but no
one ever said that if the referees are
moving these footballs around and they
never noticed they did how big a crime
is this I mean they never it was big
enough deal Tom Brady that he spent
months
texting about it to make sure the balls
were deflated texting a guy who called
himself on taxes the deflator you get
right giving him soon because an
autocratic juries the do later yeah big
deal okay like aaron ed yeah the tight
end okay after the right order right
come on let's put it Aaron how should
the government respond to the drought
crisis Oh water can you can we talk
about water do you have any how much do
you have
yes what do you think about our water
crisis is that in your purview oh yeah I
think it's a terrible crisis I think
there's a mismanagement clearly in the
state of California with our water
system it's going to have to be
completely relooked at you know we have
water problems you know I've been
working on the Gardena situation here in
California and I'm still stumped why we
don't make it some national priority
that we start taking look at our water
supplies and our water systems and the
lack of it the pollution of it and what
we're going to do when we don't have it
Carly Fiorina says it's liberals for now
and she does environmentalists wouldn't
let us build any new reservoir Obama
melted the snowpack
that's right uh Alex will the Clinton
cash scandal continue to dog Hillary's
campaign and a number of it's dogging it
now yeah the polling shows that she's
gotten even stronger and so if that's
what dogging is I'm sure the Clintons
would bring it say bring it on what it
looks like do you think that's because
the Clintons have become sort of like
like John Gotti the Teflon Don I mean at
some point oh you were accepting money
but we're real surprised by that I think
we kind of thought that was the case I
think they went to a larger systemic
failure in our political system which is
the idea of money coming in from
unsavory groups and maybe having a
disproportionate influence on the
political system is now but don't you
think that that's not good so listen how
about this out whether or not we're
talking about Bill Clinton and Monica
Lewinsky Anthony Weiner Todd you really
just bring up monocle Owens yeah Tom
Brady is really like that you are we
gonna start hearing well no I'm gonna
tell you I'm gonna tell you what tell
you what tell you listen rule it [ __ ] I
like to load law not in golf
when golf if you have Lewinsky on the
field and sorry I'm going to follow
these cases
in my opinion and I'm generally curious
this to yours on all of these cases from
Bill Clinton to Tom Brady to Hillary
Clinton this isn't The Lying the greater
sin the the sociopathic lying the way
Anthony Weiner can look into a camera
and go what me it's called politics I
mean everybody like but my wait isn't it
matter what you lie about isn't lying
about [ __ ] way less important than
lying about the things Republicans lie
about like whether it's like like global
warming isn't real do you think weapons
of mass destruction true who has degrees
from Princeton and Harvard do you really
think he thinks global warming is a hoax
or does he know it's true but he tells
that to the rubes who vote for him high
stable E which is the worst lie I
genuinely like debating you one of your
great failings is your inability to see
the intellectual response in the global
warming debate though the response which
is okay I predict the future well that's
what I do anyway well it's not like if
you can't predict the future so why
should we do anything why do ian's why
arable is dictating what the climate
will be 100 years from now and you're
going to give me the Celsius it will be
that is unless on what are you talking
about I mean the point you have to be a
seer to make policy right what is that
in the adventure Frances terrible
Republicans gray verbal Kint kids should
women be able to have abortions after 20
weeks I'm you know they have plenty to
say on that but when you ask about
global warming I'm not a scientist and
I'm a diamond
you don't you don't think it's arrogance
to look in the face of every scientist
on the planet who doesn't work for shell
and tell them I know just as well as you
do what's going on really no that's not
the argument that's that's my original
point you don't seem to understand the
opposition's argument which is not that
the scientists are wrong about where we
are today but there's hubris in
predicting 100 years of temperatures
with millions when it's blood 100 years
it's happening they're like no but that
this is happening that warming is
designed to prevent something that has
not yet happened the global warming
powerful that is not true it was in like
two minutes hours in Los Angeles not you
and me but everybody you know it's yeah
is that because of climate change or not
well here's the thing you cannot say any
specific event is directly attributed to
sort Clemens we don't know because if
there are absolutely of course have
always been hurricanes and bad storms
and all the [ __ ] but that's like saying
you know what I don't know which bag of
Cheetos gave me cancer but I I ate [ __ ]
forever and I smoked and not I don't
know which cigarette did it but I do
know that putting toxins in my body is
going to make me sick and putting toxins
in the atmosphere is going to make us
all sick
so no was was Hurricane sandy global
want maybe not but basically something
is going which stage one in the debate
because the next stage is what are you
going to do about it and what's the
cost-benefit analysis of your proposal
in your solution to fix something that
you're predicting will be the case in 50
so but but your argument is let's stick
with the old technology when actually
it's a win-win because new technology is
always what goose is the economy so if
we went full and that's why other
grown-up countries are going full on
keeping the Chinese
grownup grownup for green energy what
would you put would you put your kids
would you have them grow up in a world
where the oil and gas industry is
writing environmental policy are you
happy with that future see you guys
always box your seriously like that
status quo the answer is this I know I'm
happy to have your children grow up in a
world where environmental and energy
policy is being written by oil and gas
your drawing is too broad you're saying
environmental policy versus climate
change policies not one in the same all
right okay this questions I parted with
bad ethics by the Clintons I'd like to
state that for the record
all right here's final question this is
for you Lincoln if you run for president
and now that you've declared we know you
are hello so we're getting close bill
what would distinguish you from other
candidates certainly my record and that
is one first of all of high ethical
standards over 30 years as a mayor when
you say governor and as a United States
Senator are you saying I'm the question
what will distinguish you from other
candidates and I guess we're talking
about the Democratic candidates that
seems like a left-handed slap at Hillary
yeah at the coast I think it's important
so you don't think she has high ethical
standards look at the record look at the
wreck over that's white water or whether
it's white well I wanted it he goes I
never had this on the show last week
chemstar who was the Sun rose more year
one who follow that dying sound like him
but wait i jealous and I'm gonna repeat
it can we saw her was the special
prosecutor looked into all of that [ __ ]
and his report said I got nothing but
the [ __ ] how about the what we
started out with and that is a Secretary
of State and what's happening with the
Clinton Foundation hmm president gets
500,000 for speech oh the State
Department just gave approval for the
Canadian mining company uranium mining
company be sold to the Russia but has no
connection and on and on it goes on and
never self travelgate just never stops
oh man
I only travelgate give me a long
election cycle I don't this is a winning
issue us I really don't I think I know
well that explains you know I mean I
just don't think that they're as shady
as the right would like to paint them
well I'm asked you fight nobody's
perfectly's a lot of room but whitewater
was nothing they looked into it
endlessly it really was not as your
argument their claim is your argument
that they're clean
nobody's totally waving like especially
when Ariel and everyone that's one one
more shot at the end I like to give
everybody one last ride and your hair is
going into the shock here we gotta go
thank you very much